[Música]
vladimir putin no es un político
cualquiera es el personaje perfecto para
una película de espías y la historia de
hoy tiene mucho de película de espías
hoy vamos a hablar de un enfrentamiento
entre rusia alemania y eeuu un
megaproyecto millonario y una persona
alexéi navalni que puede dar al traste
con toda la política energética de un
país tan importante como alemania estáis
listos pues vamos con el vídeo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
seguro que muchos os habréis hecho esta
pregunta alguna vez cuento poder real
tiene rusia pensad que hablamos de uno
de los países más grandes del mundo pero
que a la vez tiene un pib más pequeño
que el de italia así que porque rusia es
tan importante una de las razones es el
gas natural atentos a este mapa
[Música]
en este mapa podéis ver como media
europa depende del gasto prácticamente
todas entre europa se ha acostumbrado a
comprar casi todo su gas a su vecino del
este está cerca y es barato esto incluye
por supuesto alemán ya que depende en un
40% del gas ruso durante años la unión
europea ha estado buscando alternativas
para diversificar el gas sin embargo si
nos atenemos a los hechos la tendencia
es más que clara alemania quiere
depender aún más de ruso
nord stream 2 completará el primero de
sus dos ramales tan pronto en junio de
2021 os presento el north stream 2 un
gasoducto que conecta directamente rusia
con alemania con esta tubería gigantesca
alemania podrá garantizar el suministro
de gas ruso sin ningún problema el
proyecto ha costado 9 mil 500 millones
de euros y está a punto de terminarse la
duda es de verdad alemania va a
conseguir acabar el norte string 2 pues
atentos porque todo este proyecto está
desencadenando una disputa seria una
disputa entre alemania y eeuu y en buena
medida podemos decir que este proyecto
podría irse al traste por este señor que
veis en pantalla
alexéi navalni el opositor contra putin
más famoso de toda rusia y parte del
extranjero este hombre supone toda una
amenaza para putin tanto es así que en
verano de 2020 le envenenaron con el
famoso no dicho si seguís visual polític
desde hace tiempo ya sabéis que él no
[ __ ] que es un veneno inventado en
tiempos de la unión soviética por
supuesto naval y no es el responsable
principal de esta historia ni muchísimo
menos el protagonista pero claramente su
intento de asesinato ha sido un
catalizador
y os preguntaréis pero como alto poder
real tiene el tal naval vi porque
alemania tiene tanto interés en comprar
gas a rusia y por qué eeuu quiere
impedirlo hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes les presento
a la tan política la newsletter sobre
análisis de latinoamérica que hemos
creado junto a la consultora pérez
perspectives por sólo cinco dólares al
mes
recibiréis tres boletines semanales con
el mejor análisis político y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos pero porque
iba a pagar por información pensando
como una inversión más que como un gasto
tanto si queréis hacer negocios en
latinoamérica como si estáis buscando
una oportunidad de trabajo en este
continente la tan política os permitirá
poner en contexto todo lo que ocurre en
esta región tenéis toda la información
en latam polític puntocom y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la cara b de la desnuclearización si hay
un país anti nuclear por antonomasia ese
es alemania de hecho uno de los partidos
más importantes en este país son los
verdes que se fundaron para pedir el
cierre de las centrales nucleares
décadas después de su nacimiento podemos
decir que han conseguido salirse con la
suya
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en el año
2002 la energía nuclear suponía el 19
por ciento del mix energético de
alemania hoy en día en el año 2021 está
en el 3% y el plan es llegar al 0% lo
antes posible
sin embargo alemania también es el mayor
consumidor de energía de toda europa así
que al prescindir de la nuclear alemania
tiene que producir más energía con otras
fuentes de que fuentes hablamos pues
atentos a este gráfico
como veis alemania cada vez tiene más
energías verdes pero todavía no se puede
depender al cien por cien de las
energías verdes porque pues por qué
almacenar energía es muy caro y un
molinillo eólico o un panel solar solo
producen energía cuando hay viento o hay
sol así que que otras alternativas hay
o la más simple es el carbón pero
también es la más contaminante que
existe así que cuál es la última
alternativa que nos queda
[Música]
exacto el gas natural podríamos decir
que el gas natural es la fuente de
energía menos contaminante dentro del
grupo de las contaminantes para que os
hagáis una idea el carbón expulsa a la
atmósfera 820 toneladas de gases de
efecto invernadero por cada gigavatio de
energía producida el petróleo está en
unas 720 toneladas el gas sin embargo
está en 420 toneladas es decir que
contamina la mitad que el carbón en
otras palabras podríamos decir que en el
mundo de hoy el gas es el nuevo petróleo
y alemania es la prueba de ello
[Música]
en 1990 producían 40 mil gigavatios de
energía por gas en 2020 ya producían más
de 94 mil gigavatios es cierto que en
términos relativos el gas representa un
porcentaje menor en el mix pero recordad
que la demanda de energía de alemania
aumenta año tras año y todo apunta a que
en el futuro será muchísimo más para que
os hagáis una idea a día de hoy alemania
consumen 90 bcm de gas al año es decir
90.000 millones de metros cúbicos de gas
al año pues bien se estima que en 2003
de 4 será más de 110 veces dicho de otra
manera que alemania necesita cada vez
más gas la pregunta es cómo se compra
ese gas pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
desde rusia con amor el gas natural
viaja de dos formas distintas por
tubería a través de gasoductos o en
barco con la tecnología del gas natural
licuado en este caso el gas se convierte
en líquido se transporta cómodamente y
se lleva al país de destino una vez ahí
el gas licuado se procesa en una planta
para convertirlo de nuevo en un gas el
problema con esta tecnología es que es
cara y requiere de tener al menos una de
esas plantas para procesar el gas y
diréis tiene alemán y algunas de estas
plantas pues por el momento
es cierto que hay proyectos para
construir una pero por el momento todo
el gas viene por gasoductos y el 40% de
ese gas viene de rusia y ojo porque no
son los únicos que compran gas a este
país atentos a este mar
[Música]
como veis otros países como finlandia
rumanía dependen en un 100% del gas ruso
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
donde está el problema
estos son los de visual político otra
vez con su odio visceral hacia rusia
acaso lo compramos gas y petróleo a
países mucho más autoritarios pues si
tenéis razón
putin no es ni de lejos el peor de los
tiranos que vende recursos naturales al
resto del mundo pero también tenemos que
reconocer una cosa putin si está
dispuesto a usar su gas como arma
política es más no sería la primera vez
que lo hace
por ejemplo en el año 2006 corto el gas
que iba para ucrania por una disputa
política tres años más tarde volvió a
hacerlo y esta vez el corte afectó
también a alemania y diréis pero porque
que tiene que ver ucrania con alemán
pues atentos a este mapa
en este mapa podéis ver los gasoductos
por dónde va al gas ruso que compra
alemania si os fijáis hasta 2011 casi
todo ese casas pasaba o por ucrania o
por bielorrusia en otras palabras que
hay si los ucranianos se quedaban sin
gas los alemanes también así que cuál es
la solución más pragmática es muy
sencillo construir un gasoducto que
conecte directamente rusia con alemania
una tubería que cruce el báltico pues
bien ese fue el proyecto nord stream 1
que se terminó de construir en 2012 sin
embargo alemania necesita aún más gas y
no quiere volver a utilizar los
gasoductos que pasan por ucrania
así es como de los creadores de nord
stream uno llegó north stream 2 la
venganza
[Música]
y ya sé lo qué pensaréis muchos dónde
está el problema a fin de cuentas no ha
cambiado nada nos guste o no rusia ya
vendía su gas a europa lo hacía antes
del norte escritos y antes del nord
stream 1 la única diferencia era por
donde viajaba ese gas y si tenéis razón
pero hay una víctima muy clara en esta
historia
ucrania pensadlo bien si rusia puede
enviar su gas sin pasar por ucrania
podrían cortarles el suministro sin
problemas de un día para otro ucrania
estaría a merced de rusia y todo esto
explica por qué los primeros países en
levantar la voz de alarma fueron todas
las repúblicas ex comunistas
y siete países de la unión europea se
oponen al nord stream estos siete países
incluyen polonia república checa los
bálticos y en general todos los países
que pertenecieron a la órbita soviética
y entonces es cuando angela merkel dijo
mira como tiemblo los países
excomunistas se enfrentan a mi andar
iros a vuestra casa
polonia cómprate un heavy y pelea te con
el así es como en 2015 la rusa gazprom
comenzó la construcción del gasoducto de
repente el mar báltico se volvió a
llenar de barcos con grúas diseñados
para poder desplegar los tramos de
tubería que van por el mar hablamos de
uno de los proyectos de ingeniería más
fascinantes que se pueden ver un
proyecto que ya ha costado más de 9.500
millones de euros parecía que nadie
podría pararlo y entonces es cuando
llega el siguiente actor de nuestra
historia
[Música]
la presión de eeuu eeuu y alemania
siempre han sido grandes aliados y esto
no se debe únicamente a que ambos sean
parte de la otan mientras francia le ha
dado la espalda eeuu en muchos frentes
como por ejemplo la guerra de irak
alemania siempre ha ido de la mano de
eeuu en política exterior y por eso esta
noticia es tan sorprendente
nord stream 2 trump aprueba sanciones en
el oleoducto ruso y ya sé lo que estará
pensando alguno esto sería alguna a
bravuconada más de donald trump verdad
pues nada de eso de hecho estas
sanciones fueron aprobadas en el
congreso tanto por demócratas como por
republicanos hay muchas razones por las
cuales eeuu quiere evitar a toda costa
que se construya este gasoducto la
primera es geopolítica pura y dura le
interesa proteger a ucrania que es un
país aliado y no le interesa que rusia
tenga tanto poder la segunda es
económica eeuu quiere vender su gas
natural licuado a europa y todo esto
explica que estas primeras sanciones
fueran suficientes como para que algunas
empresas ya abandonaron el proyecto ya
el 2019 el 6 que es una empresa suiza de
construcción de oleoductos en altamar
abandonó el north stream 2 para evitar
las acciones sin embargo en ese momento
ninguna empresa había recibido un
castigo económico real cierto eeuu
aprobó la posibilidad de imponer
sanciones económicas a todas las
empresas envueltas en ese proyecto pero
hasta ese momento no existía una
oposición tan fiera contra ese gasoducto
todo cambio en verano de 2020
científicos suecos y franceses confirman
que navalny fue envenenado con no [ __ ]
de nuevo alexéi navalni es quizás el
mayor enemigo político de vladimir putin
el novillo que es un potentísimo veneno
utilizado principalmente por los espías
rusos todo apunta a que este hombre ha
sido envenenado por gente cercana a
putin y aunque en navalia ha sobrevivido
y ha recibido tratamiento en un hospital
alemán esta noticia lo cambia
absolutamente todo
de repente francia que no tenía una
postura clara con respecto al nord
stream 2 ha pasado al club de los países
que se oponen antes era una cuestión de
geopolítica pura y dura ahora también es
una cuestión de ética y derechos humanos
podría verse como una forma de castigar
a putin por intentar asesinar a sus
opositores políticos igual modo el
asesinato de kaesong y ha dado al traste
con muchos de los grandes proyectos de
bin salman en arabia saudita el intento
de asesinato de naval ni podría dar al
traste con el gran proyecto de vladimir
putin para que os hagáis una idea una de
las últimas medidas de donald trump
antes de dejar la casa blanca fueron
nuevas sanciones económicas para frenar
el proyecto es más en el momento en el
que hacemos este vídeo más de 18
empresas han decidido abandonar este
proyecto y la pregunta la gran pregunta
que se estaréis haciendo ahora es y qué
va a hacer
joe biden en principio baiden está en
contra del gasoducto pero por otro lado
tampoco quiere enfrentarse a alemania
así que cuál es su respuesta es nada más
y nada menos que ponerse de perfil
atentos
todos unidos sanciona a un buque ruso en
la construcción del oleoducto nordstream
2 en el mar báltico en otras palabras
vaivén ha dicho que mantendrá las
sanciones de trump pero sólo para
empresas rusas el buque ruso en cuestión
se llama fortuna y es uno de esos barcos
constructores de los que se hablaba
antes un barco con enormes grúas que
pueden desplegar todos los tramos de
tubería en alta mar pues bien tanto ese
buque como todos los demás que le ayudan
a construir el gasoducto recibirán
sanciones económicas y diréis son
suficientes estas medidas como para
frenar el proyecto en principio todo
apunta a que no de hecho días después de
que se anunciaran estas sanciones contra
el fortuna el buque volvió al trabajo
como si no hubiera pasado nada
[Música]
en el momento en el que hacemos este
vídeo solo faltan por construir 148
kilómetros de los mil 230 kilómetros que
tendría en total en otras palabras que
parece casi imposible que estas
sanciones tan tímidas vayan a acabar con
el proyecto no obstante en washington
los republicanos están dispuestos a dar
la batalla
de cruz pospone el nombramiento de
bailén de barnes como director de la fia
por el oleoducto nordstream dos os
prometí una historia de espías y aquí la
tenéis de cruz y otros senadores
republicanos se han plantado y han dicho
que no aprobarán el nombramiento del
nuevo director de la cia hasta que
bailen no apruebe sanciones más duras
contra rusia y contra todos aquellos que
quieran construir el norte estrictos
para que esas sanciones fueran efectivas
también tendrían que afectar a las
empresas alemanas no olvidéis que si
todo va según lo previsto este mismo
verano se habrá terminado casi todo el
gasoducto es decir que si realmente
quieren frenar lo tendrán que tomar
medidas drásticas y si esto incluía
sancionar a uno de sus aliados más
importantes puede que esto parezca una
historia menor pero realmente hablamos
de uno de los grandes dilemas de europa
por un lado tanto alemania como toda la
región han disfrutado durante décadas de
un gas natural barato el lado de
estrictos ayudaría a que la industria
europea fuera más competitiva pero por
el otro lado supondría una amenaza para
ucrania un país de 44 millones de
habitantes que lleva años en una crisis
terrible en parte por sus malas
relaciones con rusia así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que el
nord stream 2 es una buena idea pensáis
que se terminará de construir o tal vez
de eeuu va a ser capaz de frenarlo
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual polític sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle al a
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]